"Oh, I'm not in the mood".
Who here has ever
told a partner that before?
(Laughter and murmuring)
We've all done this.
And if you haven't said it,
then you've probably heard it.
Intuitively, we understand
that our minds matter
when it comes to sex,
but we’re quick to focus
on bodies, touch and sensation
as the most crucial elements.
We're less likely to consider
the role of our imaginations.
In many parts of our life,
we are really great at imagining.
Things like vacations
or dream homes or career moves.
These exercises in imagination
help us define what it is we want.
They allow us to flirt
with what's possible
before having to make any decisions.
And they're also innately pleasurable,
even if those fantasies
never actually materialize.
Imagination is such a powerful tool.
So when it comes to sex, why isn't it
one of the first ones that we reach for?
When I first started doing research
on arousal and desire,
I learned that for women,
cognition is as important to arousal
as the presence of sexual stimuli.
In other words, using their memories,
fantasies and some focus,
women can turn themselves on
with their thoughts.
This particular study focused on women,
and much of my own work is also focused
on people who are female identifying.
But this much is clear
regardless of gender identity:
the brain is the biggest sex organ,
and everyone can benefit
from expanding their sexual imagination.
I first started thinking
about this connection
between sex and imagination
while I was in college.
Back then, among my friends,
the definition of sex
was extremely narrow.
It essentially meant penetrative sex
between a guy and a girl.
And masturbation
wasn't a topic of conversation.
Frankly, I think that solo sex
was seen as a last resort,
a desperate or lonely act
instead of a fundamentally
empowering exploration.
One morning, a friend of mine
was telling me
about her latest unsatisfying hookup,
and I asked her what
she had been thinking about during sex.
"Hmm," she said.
“I don’t know.”
Something about that really struck me.
Her entire memory of the experience
was what had happened physically.
So many of us think that good sex
is something that should happen to us,
that it’s in someone else’s hands,
quite literally,
We expect a partner, current or future,
to be the magical unlock.
Maybe because we feel
especially safe with them
or attracted to them
or because they have
more experience than we do.
But in doing so, we forget
our own agency in the matter.
We write ourselves and our imaginations
out of the pleasure equation.
I had this hunch that my friend,
that many of us, were experiencing
a crisis of inspiration.
In the years after college,
my fascination with the role
of imagination and sexuality only grew.
Eventually, I left the career I'd built
to start a company called Dipsea,
which creates stories, audio stories,
designed to turn women on.
I decided to focus on audio
because it's so immersive
and so evocative and so personal.
Here's what I mean.
Feel free to close your eyes
and consider where these sounds take you.
(Birds chirping)
(Water flowing)
OK. Open your eyes.
Were those not the sounds
you were imagining I'd play?
(Laughter)
Here's what comes to my mind.
I'm in the mountains.
I can feel the sunshine on my face.
I can feel the cool chill
coming up off the Alpine water.
I can see the tiny flecks
of sparkle in the granite.
I bet that every person in this room
is imagining something a little different,
but filled with all sorts of distinct
details about the surroundings,
about the circumstances.
Audio is incredible that way.
Erotic audio stories
have characters and plot,
but like the sounds you just heard
create a blueprint for your mind
to then fill in the blanks.
They allow you to develop
your own vision of what's appealing
in a way that can get lost
when you see something specific
or explicit onscreen.
You may not be ready or interested
in dipping a toe
into erotic audio stories.
And that's OK.
So today I'm going to walk you through
how you might get started
creating your own stories
and activating
your own sexual imagination.
I won't take this too far.
You don't have to follow along right now.
But consider this a guide
for the next time
you get a little me time.
(Laughter)
First, you'll want to settle
into your mind
the same way that you
might start a meditation.
Then imagine that your mind
is like a projector.
Everything you can see and experience
is what's right in front of you.
Everything to your left,
right, behind you,
that's out of frame.
This is important because
while there are thoughts that turn us on,
there are also thoughts that are
incredibly effective at turning us off:
stress, shame, insecurities,
and also the things
that inexplicably ick us out.
So when a thought appears
that isn't working,
and it inevitably will,
you'll be able to sweep it out of frame.
You can start with your senses.
Imagine colors, textures, sounds, images,
anything that gives you sensory pleasure.
Sometimes I like to imagine
cherry blossoms
softly floating down from trees.
Or I use a fiery pinkish orange
or a relaxing blue as a backdrop
for the experience that I'm imagining.
Next, try places.
And keep in mind that setting
will be more important
to some of us than to others.
Reach back into your memory
to that secluded beach
you visited many years ago.
Or create a setting from scratch
with as much privacy and comfort,
or as many adventurous stakes as you like.
Next think about a person
and layer on a narrative.
Maybe it's a character
from one of your favorite books.
Maybe it's your girlfriend.
Hey, maybe it's a guy in a kilt.
Whoever it is, how do they approach you?
What's motivating them?
What energy are they coming to you with?
What about you? What do you say?
And what do you do together?
And when you find something
that you really like,
play it out for a while.
You’ll have just designed your own story.
The more you flex this muscle,
the more you'll understand
what turns you on
and be able to communicate
those things to a partner.
You can share the entire fantasy
with them if you're comfortable.
That kind of disclosure
can be very intimate and affirming.
Or ...
don't.
It is not a betrayal
to use your imagination
to bring you more pleasure.
Fantasy is a safe space,
and it's time we bust the myth
that what you fantasize about
and what you want to happen in reality
are always the same thing.
So allow me to offer us
a bigger definition of what sex is.
Sex isn't just a physical act.
It's a mental experience.
And it isn't wholly
dependent on a partner.
It starts with you.
You're the one in control
of creating the most pleasure for you.
You're the protagonist.
As much as you love someone
or feel attracted to them,
they are playing a supporting role.
And you for them.
Sex is an avenue to accessing feelings
of aliveness, empowerment,
joy and confidence
innate to all of us.
That aliveness,
that is the impact of sexual wellness.
And you will feel it
walking down the street,
entering any conversation,
navigating any relationship.
Put that way,
none of us can afford
not to prioritize sex.
It isn't a nice-to-have
or an if-I-get-to-it,
dead last on our list
right after picking up the dry cleaning.
So the next time you notice
that you haven't been
in the mood for a while,
carve some time out for yourself
and let your imagination
tell you a sexy story.
Thank you.
(Applause)